[Music]
what's up screen junkies you are here
for the honest trailer commentary for
the film baby driver where we'll be
talking about the honest trailer are
real thoughts about the movie and if you
stick around to the end you'll see some
deleted scenes and outtakes and stuff
like that guys hey hey hello I didn't
really want to do this movie but you
voted for it so here we are this defines
by popular demand yes we didn't do it
when it came out because we were like
what are we gonna say yeah yeah but
people kept asking for kept asking and
asking and so we put it to a Twitter
vote so if you didn't see it I apologize
we were full on Cameron in the car just
like he'll just keep calling me and
asking for it it was either this or
Blade Runner
20:49 which I would have loved to you
know revisit and kind of honor and and
chide and all everything in between but
now you pick baby drivers the movie that
I watched and I was like okay we did
showgirls so now we do baby deer right
you got a average those two out yeah for
me this movie was a victim of hype where
if I went inside unseen I probably
would've liked a lot more but I went in
hearing several people describe it as
the second coming and the best action
movie you'll see etc and I was like that
yeah that was cool but that okay that's
not fair yeah I saw I wish I could go
see it with virgin eyes nothing I don't
already have virgin eyes no the married
man yes I almost wish he had gone
further with this movie cuz like it
starts off like real real choreographed
and I kind of wish he had just just
doubled down even more and like every
frame of this thing was like court music
and and yeah dancy that was my favorite
part was every time that things would
intentionally are like II like the
lyrics were like spray painted on you
know it's alleyways behind him and stuff
like that and it was like a music video
mm-hmm but it wasn't enough of a music
video or it kind of like dropped that
thread that it would kind of go in and
out yeah I don't know I'm
as you know I have a huge Edgar Wright
fan and I almost kind of view each film
of his as another brick and or another
piece of a mosaic that I haven't yet no
one is yet to kind of look back at
because I feel like you know there are a
lot of his movies that are hyper
specific and they just kind of fit into
these little slots because I you know I
think this is if you want to talk about
the to the Titan this for me was his
technically like him saying like I am
going to be technically precise and
exacting I mean this is one of the most
brilliantly assembled movies that I can
see and I think it's his most
technically built movie out of all of
them as far as just like I think he he
kind of set out it's almost like a
filmmaking exercise in a lot of ways
it's kind of how I review Dunkirk I kind
of view Dunkirk a baby driver very
similarly in the sense that I think
they're both brilliantly put together on
a technical level I just felt that this
movie was a little more short and it
steps that way that I didn't think there
were deficits in other areas sure I like
the best possible Vimeo real yeah yeah
but for me this was just kind of a
little kind of corner right career and
then you know as we step back just I
think every one of them is different but
I realized to be would say like well
that's not enough I get it if that
wasn't enough for one movie I understand
but for me this was someone that's just
kind of obsessed with him as a filmmaker
sure I love this particular entry for
the fact that it was very much his kind
of just like I'm gonna go crazy and try
it out yeah oh one crazier man I want
that I want every single syllable to be
synced to like a maraca or something
like that
I want the Blue Man Group the high screw
yeah I liked it again I did like the
movie but it just wasn't more than the
sum of its parts to me it was like cool
scene dialogue cool scene dialogue over
music so it was just like um it had that
kind of like outsider's view of
Americana that just never quite added up
like those things are almost I get it
it's like a heightened criminal reality
and stuff like that it's
to be the real world bids like just some
some things felt off to me
sure and I actually really didn't like
the dialog until about halfway through I
decided that it was on the nose on
purpose
hmm and then it kind of sat better with
me yeah because there I mean everything
else is pretty like on the nose and
heightened in it so I was like okay I
think I think this is on purpose
I actually thought talking about the
Americana everything I've ever seen
Edgar Wright make takes place in England
and it took me a long time before I
recognized Atlanta as not England just
because I was like why would I go right
not me in England it makes so much more
sense for Jon Bernthal and Kevin Spacey
and Ansel Elgort to be in England for no
reason it's so hard to wrap around
technically you know well actually
pilgrim took place in Canada ah that's
just true this is true which is
basically it used to be in England Jr
yeah it's European
yeah there's European flavors Montreal
little French action there too but yeah
I think that um this was a movie that
both of my parents loved and I think
that's also because it had like a young
like cute boy who was really into like
old music yes for us that could have
been our son it could have been our son
he used to love whatever we'd play a
little a little pump a little van and
all the levels yeah I would watch a
little remake of all the little rappers
oh if there was all the lols yeah from
Wayne too but they were like the
borrower's those little yeah but that
movie's problematic fury well oh yeah
tech people I will agree that the hype
on this movie was because it debuted at
one of the film
in Austin I forget which one fantastic
Festa maybe but like the hype I had to
stop listening at a certain point
because you're right it was yeah just
that it was good as like this is the
most incredible motion picture ever
assembled in the history of it and it's
correct there's a lot of it's great oh
great things about it there's some
things there's like okay but yeah the
hype on this thing was ridiculously like
nothing could have compared if you're
just going in based on the hype yeah I
agree it was it was overhyped but not
because it was bad it's just nothing
could have don't blame a movie for that
but how hyped you guys to watch the
honest trailer of it
[Music]
you've been obsessed with everything
Edgar Rudd has ever made and everything
he hasn't made now prepare to be
obsessed with a movie he's been obsessed
with for the last 22 years 22 dang if
he'd made it back then Anza would have
been an actual baby driver
baby cries talking yep it's a hard put
together me baby 2017 chiefest Halloween
costume
he's a Mozart with a go-kart but a Dane
Cook of being a crook sorry name pocket
rhymes
well I mean it gets a little obnoxious
after a while he was huge and I'm just
in the front referring him treats you're
giving a shocker
it's like it's just the energy drink of
stand-up comedy it's a it's a little
much he burned bright and also at
rhyming with crook and I think the the
comparison isn't like he's a bad
criminal per se it's that he's boy he's
unsubtle he's not keeping things low-key
there you go
much like Dane Cook there you go sorry
Dane Cook fish was using his criminal
alias in public and baby baby robbing
wearing the same outfit before during
and after his heists not wearing gloves
are wiping down its prints and making
his own recorded evidence of criminal
conspiracies why don't any of these
criminals work with his snitch he
doesn't even have a neck tag that's that
you know someone doesn't have a real job
get ready for awesome stunt driving like
that other mostly silent heartthrob with
a signature jacket in the movie with
driving the title featuring jaw-dropping
getaways that are one part there's a
better driver in part iPod baby or the
driver baby it's been a long time since
I saw Drive feel like I saw baby drive
more than I think baby's a better
technical driver yeah I do think baby
has better technical skills but I think
that driver drive drive man drive emic
drive man drive you knew his way around
the city more like he really had it
like mapped out the little alleyways and
he seemed to like have the whole place
up in his head there's no improvisation
yeah like maybe in a neutral medium
babyhood would win but if I'm like the
streets of Los Angeles or with time to
prepare I gotta go sure cut yeah because
you know what happens when driving with
driver ton of the driving Tintin you
know he hangs that right that he always
knows is a sure thing and there's like a
recycling truck you know yeah two guys
are wheeling a big plate of glass across
yeah I gotta go with baby it's the fruit
cart festival well that didn't stop him
in the past won't stop soon now crew
cart and chicken crate festival Los
Angeles areas one of my favorite things
to do here is it we have so much culture
it is let's keep watching
featuring jaw-dropping getaways that are
one part bullet one part iPod commercial
and three parts
okay go video make music videos
money stacking see I want the whole
movement vision of white boy dancing
[Music]
okay like spinning around moving
faulting your stars to Susy and
everybody's got to move stop
cut it out baby
geez never get on my nerves just give
him the sandwich baby
strap it in for babies last job for the
creepy bank-robbing ringleader doc who's
even more creepy because he's played by
a pre scandal Kevin Spacey who's even
more creepy because he says stuff like
this to a young man you are my lucky
charm who's even more creepy because he
carries a little box of kids toys around
with him we just put christopher plummer
space on him yeah that's better
boss so that was of course the elephant
in the room is the question I think
that's what we didn't want to do this
movie in the first place cuz it came out
on blu-ray or whatever right around for
so many reasons
yeah but even doing now with the with
the the benefit of time and sanity it
was still just like do we mention it do
we not it's weird if we don't but it's
weird if we also don't so definitely
make some more menacing in the movie and
then when he like pulls kind of a good
guy move in the end you like what this
was a weird choice but that's bringing
the outside in to the it ruined my
favorite line of the movie nobody takes
candy I don't enjoy taking candy from a
baby
well the thing about quoting Monsters
Inc whines back part of the movie now
it's a shame you said that
yeah it's forever tainted for right I
think plumber was like the first thing
we when they were it was clear we were
gonna do baby driver I think that was
the first sentence in the room yeah
there you go oh so you'll now see from
here on out whenever Kevin Spacey's and
recast but now we can do how some talk
if you want to know what a house of
cards trailer from us would look like
right there yeah more disturbing
translator and speaking of creepy
experience a love story between a boy
and the girl who's clearly a standing
for the boys dead mom
Debbie sings to baby just like mom used
to feeds him up the children's menu
you know that's a kid's menu right it
works the same diner that she did used
to work here sometimes but she was a
singer too I guess
Oedipus driver doesn't quite have the
same ring to it anything about that baby
do you like music
not as much as I do right you plebe
sound full of songs to obscure for the
awesome mix Egyptian reggae but too
mainstream for Tarantino plus a
recording studio so adorkable it could
date Zooey Deschanel
what is that carb pain and overall music
experience on the way to soccer practice
tell us in the comments yeah yeah I
don't know I don't know any that work he
was not a he was a much better driver
than he was a beat maker yeah a set I
know Froot Loops Froot Loops that's what
it was I mean the guy's got like 500
grand under the floorboards like get a
laptop buy a kit yeah yeah Garage Band
hey crash pit I choose to think that
this exists in it the continual outside
of time yeah that one's watching on tube
televisions there's cassette players but
he has an iPod but it's a first it's
like it's got a bunch of iPods comes the
20 iPod it's you old one yeah I think
that's why it's so charming that he has
all the iPods right and like their each
one's for a different mood it's like
there's playlist baby you just you make
the playlist in iTunes and then you load
them in your one iPod yeah although I
get it like if you're sort of a pack rat
there was that couple of years where you
probably had a thousand iPod shuffles
because people were just handing them
out you'd go to like TGI Fridays it
sounds easy but they're all like the big
the big clunky you know I think now I
realized this is why my parents like is
because he has the same level of
understanding of technology that they do
or they like I need a new album put it
on my new iPod just like before like one
for each Bruce Springsteen or whatever
you know that's about yeah that's keep
God could date Zooey Deschanel
we couldn't think of a more modern
replica there's a more who's the new
Zooey Deschanel who's the quirky like
she's not like the other girls girl let
us know in the comments we got still
week we checked out sometime or a new
girl and a train that's pretty much rain
yes yes that's a window you can hear it
and see it I still asked my Google home
some dumb stuff you keep watching so if
you're too much of a hipster to like
Basten the Furious enjoy Edgar Wright
school my car flake that was his highest
performer at the box office today even
though he doesn't even drive a single
baby Oh false advertising now boss baby
there's a film that delivers on the
title let's indeed a boss and story baby
baby skids rods it's the movie beibei's
kids don't know mark fan of early 90s
live-action/animated diffusion times its
back yeah tone loke is the voice of the
baby yep I forget amazing stand-up
comics name is that it's even based on
but it's one unforgettable trip to UM
Wally's world yeah yeah should re-watch
that anyway look at that one's for us
this trailers for you that lemon zest
baby skids rip Draper towaway zone
driving this crazy downshift a bee flee
way me at the lady from American sniper
a fake baby explaining what tinnitus is
ten oh yeah he had an accident with a
big head he's still gonna humming the
drum yes sir
is tinnitus his own and can the
Christopher Plummer read that auto right
city your real name is miles great
because I needed more help getting miles
Taylor on so Elgort and the ready player
one guy confused I don't even know the
ready player one guy's name is that's
his name
Tye Sheridan oh I'm not gonna remember
that time Cyclops okay alright well
let's roll right into a deleting scenes
then we'll chat a little bit more you
loved a satyric will take on zombie
movies buddy cop movies video games and
alien invasion slash alcoholic British
movies now Edgar Wright is taking aim at
the stylish seventies crime genre except
it's not really a satire it takes place
in this decade and the characters have
all the style of an Ed Hardy catalog
Congrats ed u bedazzled the Punisher
story my only regret is that's from a
very specific episode of Futurama where
a guy gets unfrozen from the 1980s they
couldn't they didn't have a cure for
bone-itis and they unfreeze him and he
goes and does all the 80 stuff and fry
wants to be like an 80s guy again and he
forgets to cure bone-itis and so at the
end of the episode he died as he's dying
it's only regret is that he has a bonus
yeah jokes are funny when you explain
them okay let's keep guys stock market
crash
madmen to get better crazy taxi it's
clear that he became the villain sick
bird view of a bird
needles nihilist nettutor and house of
cars master class edgar wright teaches
movie directed get ready for plant a job
Kloss baby they buzzed a out night damn
it again yeah I said we drive him to the
stall okay
is this a prequel to hurricane heist
because then I might watch that movie a
stretch but honest
did you see hurricane ice aid Wow it was
literally it was literally in one
theater in Los Angeles for one week I
missed it dang it and a very upset that
insurance will be available soon
anywhere I would mind renting a are
streaming a hurricane hi I will go to a
red box to get Hurricane heist okay I'll
just go to perfect cover for any time is
it really a heist I think you're just
grabbing things at that point if it's
like how much planning can there be was
this will find out that movie made there
was a movie with Christian Slater made
back in the 90s called hard rain exactly
like this movie it's yeah it was like a
big storm and somebody's hiked I stand
around there's that it was like the end
of his uptick where I was like Broken
Arrow yeah and then he maybe just that
yeah yeah right back down with hard rain
hard rain check that out yeah hard range
starring Christian Slater 1997 I believe
hey look at him okay well that's baby
driver
you heard what we had to say about it
guys what's your what's your driving
song if you had a you know run from the
cops what do you put on the iPod mm-hmm
that's a good question
style by Taylor Swift Oh God trying to
die it's the only song I've ever
listened to unless although if you play
that loud enough the cops won't shoot
you because they'll just assume yeah
he's fine also baby driver we didn't go
into the race thing but like they would
shoot him
for other reasons because hehe there's
like a string of dead cops behind him at
the end just like I give up like yeah he
would definitely go down I also love the
the morality what did you call it
reverse Seinfeld oh the personality baby
was the reverse sighs he's so nice
everyone every character witness shows
up like he gave me my purse like he did
smiles when he dances by me at the
coffee shop like as opposed to Seinfeld
it's the exact opposite
yeah so yeah I like to imagine that he
gets off after you know two years of
good behavior and then uh I don't know
marries his mom or whatever it is he's
trying to do he robbed thousands of
dollars and put countless lives at risk
but he mopped floors okay yeah yeah
we're all pretty big Edgar Wright fans
and if you watch just the honest
trailers you might not know it oh I like
to feel like we're uh you know Fox News
fair and balanced on him we are I think
we say like plenty of positive things
about it same with unity of the Internet
yes same with that I'm the Tucker
Carlson a good little boy and the Scott
Pilgrim on it's like yeah it's good the
thing is we haven't done the Cornetto
trilogy because they're like
unimpeachable they're perfect yeah yeah
we chat me up about while Shaun of the
Dead is my favorite movie chat me up
about while I think why I think the
world isn't is that great so there you
go spicy meatball not much to say in
those honest rows but we've we've
trimmed the edges which is a baby driver
and Scott Pilgrim so that's why guys
thanks for tuning in
come back next week and you'll see our
honest trailer commentary for something
that makes us very angry
yeah look at look at the schedule okay
what we've done look to your right look
at the schedule very figure it out very
angly no but not not thanks for watching
guys we'll see you next week no wonder
you didn't use any money
you
[Music]